[Musique]
on retrouve notre rubrique idée de
sortie avec mélanie potier qui nous a
rejoint bonsoir en sein de la rédaction
tv 78 cette semaine les rendez-vous aux
loisirs sont très technologique et oui
la commanderie à elancourt a choisi de
mettre en avant les nouvelles
technologies c'est le premier temps fort
de ce premier trimestre 2020 l'atelier
des sciences propose entrer dans la
matrice est le nom de l'exposition une
exposition penser en trois temps la
première partie c'est un cabinet de
curiosité pour découvrir l'histoire des
nouvelles technologies mais aussi les
entreprises du territoire spécialisés
des innovations aussi qu'ils sont liés
au numérique avec des projets de fab lab
des projets de startups du territoire
par exemple autour des objets connectés
à l'internet des objets de la smart
cities aussi de la cybersécurité et puis
enfin un des grands défis pour le 21e
siècle le sujet de l'informatique
quantique en des notions qui peuvent
paraître compliqué on rassure les
téléspectateurs mélanie l'exposition
s'adresse à tous les publics
comme toujours les missions de la
commanderie c'est surtout d'être ludique
alors d'ailleurs la deuxième partie de
l'exposition est faite de petits jeux
d'animations qui permettent
d'appréhender tout cela on apprend à
coder une caméra identifie ce qui est
mis devant elle et la ville peut aussi
se terminer par un jeu très en vogue un
escape game
voilà c'est plutôt une escape room alors
le public à 45 minutes pour identifier
et neutraliser une source de
dysfonctionnements et de piratage sur
internet c'est un jeu qui amène à une
réflexion sur de nombreux sujets et pour
les intéresser toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur les sites qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et que
maintenant je connaissais bien la
commanderie points ce qui point fr et
kiosques pense qu'il pourrait faire
merci mélanie d'autres idées de sorties
retrouver dans votre émission 7,8
loisirs après ce journal